[Música]
y sabéis que el ser humano es el único
mamífero que sigue bebiendo leche perdón
aquí estamos el ser humano es el único
mamífero que sigue bebiendo leche
después de su edad infantil y para eso
porque somos seres profundamente hábiles
hemos decidido montar toda una industria
de la producción de leche para producir
leche necesitamos para subvenir a
nuestras necesidades necesitamos hacer
un gran esfuerzo y hacemos ese gran
esfuerzo mediante la producción masiva
de este producto este producto tiene un
subproducto que son los terneros
obviamente nunca pensamos sin - las
personas somos de ciudad que cuando
tenemos la necesidad de un determinado
producto generalmente hay una serie de
subproductos alrededor que estamos
generando pues bien los datos son un
subproducto son un subproducto de
nuestra necesidad de estar conectados
son un subproducto de nuestra necesidad
de programar de tomar decisiones de
abrir un documento word de comunicarnos
entre nosotros los datos se generan
porque sí porque están porque están ahí
porque es la propia naturaleza del
sistema el sistema genera ese
subproducto la cuestión es qué pasa
cuando el subproducto pasa
ser más valioso que lo que ocurre con el
producto principal como nos pasa con el
ternero y la leche la leche tiene un
coste importante pero va tendiendo a
cero porque se subvenciona con la
existencia de un producto o un
subproducto que es el ternero con los
datos pase exactamente igual y por eso
como seres humanos que como dice jara ya
estamos destinados a ser estúpidos y
nunca debemos de subestimar la capacidad
de nuestros de nuestra propia estupidez
hemos decidido conectar absolutamente
todo lo que tenemos en nuestras casas
todo lo que está en nuestras vidas lo
hemos conectado y seguimos generando
datos estamos creando datos de manera
involuntaria todo el tiempo cuando
barremos nuestra casa hemos decidido que
le hace falta a nuestra nuestra
aspiradora casera no sólo conocer los
contornos para no darse golpes y no
caerse por las escaleras sino que además
necesitamos que se conecte a internet le
diga al productor
dónde estamos cómo es nuestra casa y de
pronto el producto se dé cuenta que es
mucho más valioso el dato del mapa de
nuestra casa que el que la propia
producción de la máquina de barrer
el año pasado la fed aprobó por primera
vez lo que se llaman las píldoras
inteligentes esta píldora inteligente
está pensada para que aquellos enfermos
que padecen esquizofrenia se tomen la
medicación entendemos todos como
sociedad que un esquizofrénico no
medicado es un ser que puede ser
peligroso que puede apuñalar a sus
familiares a sus vecinos oye voces es un
peligro así mismo y por lo tanto como
sociedad hemos decidido quitarle la
capacidad de tomar una decisión de ser
un ser independiente de que decida no
tomarse la medicación porque entendemos
que como sociedad estamos más protegidos
cuando controlamos cuando se toma la
medicación y cuando no se la toma
grandes ventajas nos han contado que
traen los datos esa gran inteligencia
que nos va a cambiar la vida ese gran
momento en donde todos vamos a
solucionarlos en los problemas médicos
vamos a vivir eternamente o por lo menos
150 años no voy a entrar en la gran
complejidad que supone cambiar toda la
estructura social de una de un mundo en
donde vivimos 80 años razonablemente
bien y pasamos a vivir 150 todo esto
está conectado porque porque no lo vamos
a conectar porque no vamos a aprovechar
la gran ventaja que tiene tener un
montón de datos que fluyen
y que facilitan la vida de todos
nosotros la realidad es que le echamos
las culpas a los datos pensamos
generamos muchos datos con los sistemas
estos datos cada vez son más valiosos
los datos sustituyen a la producción
principal para qué voy a gastarme el
dinero en producir algo por ejemplo un
coche si lo puedo pagar con datos ya hay
proyectos en donde vamos se está
pensando francamente que es mucho más
rentable regalar los coches o dejar los
coches
conducidos en las ciudades para que se
muevan libremente para que los usuarios
se monten se logren de sus datos
personales con sus cuentas de diversas
entidades en donde están su vida
completa y que el resultado de ese
subproducto que es el dato es mucho más
valioso que el rendimiento que la propia
empresa que produce el del coche puede
llegar a dar coches gratuitos
no nos extraña esta situación porque ya
lo hacemos todos los días tenemos
comunicación gratis a cambio de datos
tenemos acceso a servicios que son
extraordinariamente caros a cambio de
datos tenemos acceso a información a
periódicos a entretenimiento a cambio de
datos porque somos una sociedad que nos
hemos acostumbrado a pensar que quién va
a tener interés en nosotros que no
tenemos nada de qué ocultar que somos
tan irrelevantes que porque alguien nos
va a regalar un coche para trasladarnos
de un sitio a otro si total estoy dando
cuatro datos que no tienen trascendencia
la realidad es que detrás del dato hay
una cosa que se llama el modelo
matemático el modelo matemático los
algoritmos de los que últimamente no
hacemos más que hablar y además hablamos
del algoritmo como la belleza de la
matemática la belleza de la neutralidad
si yo aplicó un algoritmo matemático
parece que toda posibilidad de
discriminación desaparece todos pasamos
a ser iguales las decisiones son
aparentemente racionales y además
basadas en un criterio que está dentro
de la propia de la propia fórmula
matemática no hay lugar a la
discriminación no hay lugar
que se tomen decisiones que no sean
adecuadas sin embargo y no voy a hablar
de los sesgos cognitivos llevados al
algoritmo que es eso
un gran tema de discusión sin embargo
nos encontramos con una situación que es
mucho más triste que es que hay algo
digamos bueno si hay algoritmos malos
hay algoritmos de una excelente calidad
que son transparentes sabemos qué datos
entran sabemos qué datos salen sabemos
por qué toman las decisiones y podemos
cuestionar las sin embargo hay otros
algoritmos que son una caja negra porque
un banco me niega un crédito porque no
voy a tener acceso a una determinada
hipoteca porque no mis hijos no van a
poder acceder a una determinada
universidad porque cuál es el cuál es la
razón que detrás de todo eso esa
posibilidad que además está en el alma
del aboga de discutir de discutir la
injusticia resulta que con el algoritmo
ha desaparecido nosotros hemos pasado a
considerar que este estamos en en ese
estado perfecto en donde las decisiones
son neutrales pero resulta que las
decisiones no son neutrales en absoluto
porque en los modelos
ticos que están bien hechos y en modelos
matemáticos que están mal hechos en un
estudio hecho en eeuu se demostró que
utilizando un determinado modelo
matemático utilizando big data se
llegaba a la conclusión de que todas las
personas que compran en una determinada
tienda en un porcentaje muy alto en un
ratio muy alto no eran fallaban a la
hora de pagar sus créditos no tenían un
buen historial crediticio y entonces el
sistema llegó a la conclusión de que
cualquiera que hay que comprar en esa
tienda tenía una alta probabilidad de
impagar sus créditos aunque esa persona
en concreto no hubiera pagado jamás un
crédito aunque jamás hubiera dejado de
pagar nada y aunque no fuera dejar de
pagar nada nunca por lo tanto son
sistemas que dicen tú no eres merecedor
de crédito porque tú has comprado en la
tienda equivocada estamos utilizando los
datos para hacer correlación y
futurología no para tomar decisiones que
son manifiestamente injustas o justas
simple y llanamente estandarizamos a la
mayor parte de la sociedad con los datos
y aquellos que tengan la capacidad de
hablar con un ser humano
en una situación económica mejor podrán
saltarse este automatismo y podrán
discutir esa decisión eso es lo que nos
pueden traer los modelos matemáticos y
lo que nos traen los modelos matemáticos
en muchos casos un aumento de la pobreza
y un aumento de la discriminación
pensamos qué importancia tiene darle un
like a una determinada
a una determinada actividad seguir a
fulanito a perenganito total estoy
haciendo la actividad que no tiene mayor
trascendencia si cuento algo de mi vida
a lo mejor cuento demasiado incluso hago
un modelo de negocio del hecho de contar
mi vida en redes sociales pero no tienen
especial trascendencia uno de los
grandes problemas o de las grandes
desventajas que tienen los modelos
matemáticos es que son exportables
cuando yo estoy haciendo el rating de
una persona en un en una red social que
me impide hacer un rating de esa persona
en un sitio distinto a esa red social
si esa rating me permite que esa persona
viaje gratis coma gratis le reduzca el
precio de un determinado servicio porque
no puedo extender ese modelo fuera del
estricto modelo privado es decir el
problema que tienen los modelos
matemáticos es que son como los virus se
contagia tienen tendencia a extenderse a
otras áreas distintas para las que
fueron inicialmente considerados o
incluidos
y en realidad nos podemos encontrar
pensando qué gran ventaja tiene contar
con un número elevado de likes pero en
algunas realidades distópicas que se ven
en series de televisión nos podemos
encontrar con la situación en que el
rating que nos dan los demás no sea lo
suficientemente bueno y nos convirtamos
a unos parias sociales pensamos siempre
que estamos en un futuro improbable en
un futuro que no llegará porque nos
sentimos protegidos por el sistema sin
embargo el rating social ya ha llegado a
china china tiene un sistema que ha
empezado utilizando
toda la información que los usuarios han
dado a las distintas empresas privadas a
las empresas a las empresas de
comunicación a las tiendas a las propias
redes sociales sin mayor trascendencia y
ese rating se está convirtiendo en un
rating que te permite determinar quién
es un buen ciudadano chino y quién es un
mal ciudadano chino quién tiene acceso
al crédito y quién no tiene acceso al
crédito quién es digamos peligroso o
quién forma parte de quién puede ser un
elemento susceptible de crear un
problema al sistema este sistema
pensamos claro se tiene que dar o sólo
se da en sistemas autoritarios
pensamos en china y decimos bueno esto
no va a llegar a nosotros porque
nosotros somos una sociedad democrática
en donde somos capaces de valorar en la
libertad individual donde somos capaces
de valorar la distancia que existe entre
monos entre entre un dictador y lo que
no lo es y sin embargo tengo que estar
con hararé en que las cosas no son tan
sencillas como parecen sobre todo cuando
no le damos ninguna importancia al
compartir unos datos cuando no le damos
ninguno
a contar nuestra vida porque ninguno
tenemos nada que ocultar verdad
de hecho parece como si cuando queremos
navegar por debajo del interés por
debajo del radar nos encontramos en una
situación como preocupante y pensemos en
el interés general quien no tiene
interés en evitar que su computador se
convierta en un sitio en donde se
asesina a niños de manera salvaje o en
donde no se puede salir por las noches o
en donde se producen violaciones
diariamente todos tenemos un interés en
que eso no ocurra y por qué no cogemos
los datos de las personas que tienen un
comportamiento en el pasado que pudiera
entrar dentro de esos parámetros y por
qué no cogemos los datos de esas
personas aquellos que facilitan
voluntariamente y aquellos kills
voluntaria y porque no los tratamos
todos de manera conjunta y hacemos un
patrón de comportamiento y una vez que
hemos hecho un patrón de comportamiento
porque no identificamos a esa gente de
manera individual
y porque no la controlamos de alguna
manera total ya lleva un teléfono móvil
en el bolsillo total ya tiene un
wearable probablemente a lo mejor tiene
algún elemento conectado en su casa
quien mejor manera de tener controladas
aquellas personas que pudieran ser un
peligro para la sociedad
al final acabaremos todos justificando
el pre crimen acabaremos todos en
minority report considerando que hay un
grupo de personas que tiene una
tendencia al mal que tiene una tendencia
un mal comportamiento que puede adaptar
a nuestra sociedad
pensemos en ello un momento porque no
estamos lejos de esa situación y hay
programas de pre crimen en eeuu y hay
programas de pre crimen en alemania
existen no se cuentan no se dicen que se
utilizan pero están ahí y además no dan
malos resultados porque resulta que el
subproducto que generamos de manera
voluntaria es valiosísimo y además dice
mucho de nosotros mismos pensemos en el
interés general porque el debate está en
el interés general y además es ahí donde
está el truco
vamos a permitir colar una serie de
vulneraciones de la intimidad de todos
nosotros a cambio de esa sensación de
paz común que todos queremos tener este
es es este debate el que a lo mejor
deberíamos de tener junto con los datos
en la inteligencia artificial
porque yo creo que hay derecho a navegar
debajo del radar es más nuestros
sistemas están pensados para que los
usuarios tengan un derecho a la
intimidad te puedas desarrollar como una
como un ser humano completo y pleno
quien se desarrolla como un ser humano
completo y pleno sabiendo que te están
mirando continuamente quién aceptaría
tener una persona sentada en su casa
después de cenar mirándole como come
como cena como de la televisión como
opina quién lo aceptaría pues todos
nosotros lo aceptamos de manera continua
y constante y esa es la gran cuestión
que nos debemos de plantear que no hay
nada malo en navegar por debajo del
radar que es un derecho constitucional
navegar por debajo de radar que hoy en
vigor el famoso reglamento de protección
de datos y que una de las grandes
falacias de todos es yo he leído las
condiciones de privacidad quien la se ha
aceptado de hecho esta es una página
vamos a acabar con la gran mentira de
internet nadie ha leído las condiciones
ni las he leído yo que sea abogado así
que no espero que nadie las lea y es más
todo nuestro sistema está basado en
creer que consigue cuando uno consigue
el consentimiento del usuario
resulta que ya podemos hacer con sus
datos lo que nos dé la gana vale pero
todos sabemos por qué tenemos
estadísticas de las páginas que nadie lo
ha leído que nadie lo ha abierto que
nadie lo ha entendido
sobre todo porque no saben que son un
subproducto no saben que están generando
unos datos de manera involuntaria no
saben que son no creen que lo que
cuentan es lo importante pero lo que
cuentan es lo menos relevante es lo que
no cuentan y es cómo se aplica un modelo
matemático sobre ellos lo que realmente
relevante por ello quiero lanzar una
idea que creo que es la idea que tal vez
se dice menos y que me parece la más
relevante que es que el mejor dato es el
que no se recoge
tenemos que pensar en sociedades en
donde los sistemas no generen el
subproducto por defecto los sistemas
generan muchos datos simple y llanamente
por una mala programación por una
vaquería de quien de quien lo instaló
por por por por un problema de diseño
exijamos que se recojan los datos que
sean estrictamente imprescindibles pero
es más las empresas recogen una variedad
tan enorme de datos en muchos casos por
moda en muchos casos porque les han
dicho que lo que tienen que hacer porque
el hecho que los van a monetizar de
alguna manera la realidad es que tienen
un número tan elevado de datos que no
tienen capacidad para securizar los y
todos estamos esperando expectantes a
ese gran ciber arma de donde el dato en
donde se produzca la gran fuga de datos
en donde la vida de todo el mundo quede
expuesta así que si hay algo que quiero
transmitir en el día de hoy es que el
mejor dato es el que no se recoge
exijamos que no se recojan aquellos
datos que no sean estrictamente
imprescindibles y una vez recogidos que
se borren si ya no hacen falta
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]